I published an article with some
dermatologists it's about the myth that
physical sunscreens work by reflecting
UV they don't they mostly work by
absorbing UV just like chemical
sunscreens this mist seems kind of
abstract but it does lead a lot of
people to mistakenly use mineral
sunscreens and dermatologists to
recommend mineral sunscreens to their
patients when it might not be the best
choice for them for example it might be
less comfortable to wear or harder to
make blend in with your skin that means
you'll use it less and a sunscreen that
you don't actually put on isn't going to
work it's called improving patient
communication on sunscreen Choice
updating mechanistic misconceptions it's
open access you can check it out here